en afrique deux chefs d'état sont morts
en même temps les présidents du rwanda
et du burundi se trouvaient dans le même
avion quand il s'est écrasé l'appareil
aurait été abattu par qui on ne sait pas
encore
les trois membres d'équipage français
sont moroses aussi et cet attentat a
provoqué de nouveaux troubles meurtriers
à kigali la capitale du rwanda florence
mavic cela faisait 20 ans que le général
major habyarimana était à la tête du
rwanda à la suite d'un coup d'état
un homme de poigne qui supportait mal de
voir son pouvoir remise en cause par une
opposition de plus en plus revendicative
cyprien ntaryamira était lui presque un
novice il n'occupait le fauteuil de
président du burundi que depuis janvier
dernier choisi par le parlement il se
voulait homme de dialogue
tous deux revenaient d'un sommet de
chefs d'état africains en tanzanie
leur avion aurait été abattu au moment
d'atterrir sur l'aéroport de kigali la
capitale du rwanda
pour l'instant on ne sait pas qui est à
l'origine de ce qui a tout l'air d'un
attentat à peine la nouvelle connue
kigali s'est enflammé et la communauté
francophone suit avec une certaine
crainte
les combats qui ont éclaté depuis ce
matin il ya beaucoup de tension en
entendez pire des explosions crown a
remarqué chez des indications qu'il ya
des maisons qui sont billets tubes en
mesure de vous dire exactement qui
tirent contre guy à ce stade c'est
impossible
la sécurité est telle qu'on peut pas se
permettre de se déplacer c'est
simplement trop dangereux pour tout le
monde
évidemment pour cette mélasse enfin le
pire le premier ministre du rwanda
aurait été tués ainsi que trois
observateurs militaires belges membres
des nations unies
la mort brutale les deux chefs d'état
risque de relancer la guerre tribale qui
oppose au rwanda comme au burundi deux
ethnies depuis des générations les hutus
majoritaire combattent les tutsis
minoritaires jetant sur les chemins des
milliers de réfugiés
environ 600 coopérants français demeure
au rwanda 700 au burundi voisin
peut être seront ils amenés à quitter
ces deux pays dans les jours prochains
images de guerre